growing number of olympic athletes who
are opening up about the pressures of
competing on the world stage two-time
gold medalist and u.s snowboarding
favorite jamie anderson who finished
ninth in ninth place in the slope style
event in beijing blamed her falls on her
mental struggles she said on social
media that her mental health and clarity
just hasn't been on par last year simone
biles fueled conversations about the
importance of mental health when she
withdrew from some gymnastic events in
tokyo jamie yuka spoke with several
current olympians who shared their
personal battles
in hopes of normalizing a talk about
mental health really important jamie
good morning
it is important vlad simone biles as you
said michael phelps and naomi osaka are
just some of the big name athletes who
have changed the game when it comes to
mental health now here in beijing the
u.s olympic and paralympic committee is
working to focus not only on physical
health but mental health as well and as
we've learned being in the right head
space can make or break a performance
after my last olympics i put that
pressure on myself to be perfect i would
be really sad and depressed all the time
two-time gold medalist and snowboarding
superstar chloe kim is one of the many
athletes this year prioritizing mental
health just as much as the physical we
are athletes but we're humans first and
we need to take care of ourselves as
humans first figure skater nathan chen
whose bronze medal finished four years
ago was seen as a let down took the
steps necessary to strengthen his mind
for beijing and last week won his first
gold working with a sports psychologist
you feel almost that having your mental
health in check has helped
what you do on the ice absolutely you
know i think you can
be physically perfect and so ready to go
but if mentally you're not there
not much is going to happen from the
ranks i still have days when i'm like
wow i really need a boost of confidence
here to the ski slopes and that's coming
from someone who's a defending olympic
gold medalist team usa is talking as
much about their mental health as they
are about their accomplishments until
recently athletes often fought their
mental battles alone and in silence
i feel like it's taken so long to get
the to this point is because of how
we've always
looked at athletes they're invincible
they're indestructible they can't do no
wrong they can't lose
you know they build us up on such a high
pedestal
that it's like you're not allowed to
fail
two years before winning silver and shot
put at the 2020 tokyo olympics raven
saunders hit rock bottom after she says
she was not performing at her best it
just felt like my coaches didn't care it
just felt like everyone around me didn't
care i was drowning and i was screaming
for everyone
to like help me save me but no one was
there is what it felt like in the spring
of 2016 i
what i felt happened is that i bombed
worlds and really i just
i wasn't perfect just like raven figure
skater and bronze medalist gracie gold
buckled under the pressure of becoming
number one in the world i was just very
apathetic towards my training and
towards skating
in general and i was more lethargic than
normal and it just kind of kept going
downhill from there she battled
depression and developed an eating
disorder on a really really rough day i
was
not awake for much of the day during my
depression my eating disorder swung the
other way to binge eating and grossly
overeating and i put on a lot of weight
in a very short amount of time i covered
all my mirrors up because it was
upsetting to look at myself so i simply
chose
not to look at myself
in the summer of 2017 gold showed up to
a training camp almost unrecognizable it
just seemed like i didn't want to skate
anymore and like why are you here like
you clearly just want to live a regular
life and i was thought what no i
i don't
want to some days live any life like it
is not going well at all it was a cry
for help and a year before the 2018
olympics where she was considered a gold
medal contender
gold checked into a mental health
facility for 45 days are athletes a
little different than the rest of the
population in terms of how to deal with
mental health they are the u.s olympic
and paralympic committee now prioritizes
mental health with a team of doctors
here on site in beijing i think it's
safe to say that everyone is using
somebody around sports psychology around
mental health to improve performance we
are here for anything and everything
whether it's weight maintenance and
well-being
whether it's a crisis whether you're
just feeling homesick and you want to
talk to somebody once but you actually
have a therapist back home the goal is
to be proactive not reactive and
athletes across the board are pushing
for others to find themselves outside of
their sport it took me a while to
understand the difference between who
you are and what you are but i was
thankful enough that i learned my value
and my worth and that i would be okay
without that four kilogram shot put i
will always see myself and identify as a
skater but learning that that is just
one facet
was
difficult and fundamental and that my
value as a person
doesn't increase or decrease based on
how i perform but as me as gracie
i exist and can take up space
if i get an olympic medal or if i don't
good perspective there gracie's working
on a memoir and doing an ice tour as
well this year all the athletes we spoke
with are encouraged by the new u.s opc
outreach and dr bartley says many
athletes face financial challenges
making this program necessary tony
jamie a very delicate and important
interview there and we're so glad that
gracie gold is doing better it would
appear we appreciate it continued great
coverage from beijing it you know it
just reminds us that these athletes they
carry the expectations of their fellow
countrymen and women and they go into
these games and we see them almost in
many instances as superhuman yeah and
what jamie's reporting shows is that
they're just like us and they suffer
through some of the same issues that we
suffer through but it's outsized because
of their role in society identity though
is so tied to the sport and as athlete
and it's good for them to see themselves
beyond that but i think a lot of people
have work and identity mixed up yeah so
the attributes having this conversation
i think is helpful for all of us that's
right good point
all right jamie thank you again